bonjour je vous cache pas je suis un
tout petit peu nerveux
si comme si comme moi vous avez regardé
des têtes tôt qu'avant vous comprenez
pourquoi donc
comme vous le savez je suis souffleur de
verre parler surtout dans cette
circonstance je suis pas très à l'aise
alors je vous demandais de avec moi
avant que je raconte mon histoire
si vous voulez bien de souffler une fois
merci
si vous voulez bien je vais commencer au
début
à cet âge là je suis au gabon en afrique
la lumière est ici attend ce qu'elle
fait vibrer les couleurs et nourrit les
plantes comme nulle part ailleurs
je suis un enfant fasciné dans ce milieu
il n'y a ni magasins ni internet ni télé
ont joué c'est un lance-pierre que j'ai
confectionné comme les gamins des
villages je pars à la chasse tout me
fascine les nuages les couleurs les
goûts
en 1985 mes parents décident de se
séparer si une des plus belles années de
ma vie
je me retrouve dans une banlieue à new
york chez ma grand-mère avec mon père
est mon avec ma mère et mon frère
et là j'y découvre la neige le froid
ma mère m'inscris dans une école
montessori qui est comme une école de
hippies où l'enfant est roi
j'y passe mes journées à faire des
siestes et à me déguiser
je tombe amoureux de ma prof en fin de
ma maîtresse l'univers que je viens de
quitter c'est celui là
à cet âge là je suis au pic sensorielle
de ma vie
ma mère un jour dans la cabane du jardin
face à une grande fenêtre sort un papier
et des peintures et là je découvre
quelque chose encore plus incroyable je
m'en rappelle comme si c'était hier
l'odeur de la peinture la texture dans
les doigts ma mère qui souriait soleil
qui brillait dehors et les traces de mes
doigts sur cette papier sur ce papier je
ne vous cache pas que je suis habité
cette année a été cette année a été
grande mais allez c'est fini parce que
mes parents ont décidé de se rejoindre
alors je suis reparti en afrique peu de
temps après mon arrivée en afrique un
jour dans la cuisine courant après mon
frère je tombe dans une pile de verre et
je me déchire le bras
si le début de ce que j'appelle
l'obscurité pendant des années pour les
années qui suivent
je découvre des choses que je n'avais
pas découverte avant je ressens des
choses qui me perturbe
l'injustice la pauvreté la lèpre la
malnutrition ce même environnement quels
j'habitais qui me fascinait tout d'un
coup me fait peur des fois de temps en
temps avec ma mère on pleure c'est trop
pour nous à ce même moment d'ailleurs ma
mère elle est prise d'une dépression qui
va durer des années
mon père est de moins en moins là en
1993 ma mère décide de nous quitter
elle reviendra pas un an après c'est mon
père il subit un anévrisme ne sera
jamais le même il ya en mourir à sept
ans après et du jour au lendemain je me
retrouve de pi de la nation rapatrié en
france et je suis paumé
je suis habité de colère je suis perdu
je suis blanc je suis noir je suis pieds
nus je dois mettre des chaussures je
sais pas à 18 ans je m'échappe aux états
unis là où j'avais été tellement heureux
et je découvre un jour au bout d'une
canne la lumière cette lumière que j'ai
perdus pendant tellement d'années
à ce moment là je savais pas je sais que
je vais être souffleur de verre toute ma
vie maintenant que j'ai retrouvé cette
lumière je ne veux plus la perdre alors
d'atelier en atelier je voyage et j
apprends on savoir faire qui est un
langage un langage entre mes mains et la
matière puisque pour sublimer cette
lumière pour aller au bout de mon
questionnement et de mon dialogue avec
cette chose qui me passionne et qui nous
fait vivre et qui me fait vibrer il faut
que j'apprenne à lui parler alors je
deviens un artisan mais les problèmes ne
s'arrêtent pas là en 2001 je passe par
le pare brise d'une voiture de
l'intérieur à l'extérieur
la vitre de la voiture me déchire les
paul gibert presque tout mon sens je me
casse les hanches et les côtes
en 2003 je perds ma tante qui m'a adopté
pendant des années après ça je me bats
contre une toxi manic et toc simani
toxicomanie toxicomanie sévère
à l'âge de 31 ans je suis visités par le
cancer un cancer métastasé un cancer de
la peau je me fais opérer deux fois mais
vous voyez pendant tout ce temps là j'ai
la lumière j'ai cette maille matière
incroyable entre les mains qui vit de
feu qui vit d'énergie et qui a des
règles très particulière et si je veux
m'exprimer avec il faut que j'apprenne
son langage et grâce à ce langage
je tiens je survis je vis
cette matière elle me fascine
ce qui est compliqué à ce moment là
c'est que je la vis d'un artisan n'est
pas aussi simple qu'on imagine surtout
souffleur de verre
je ne sais pas si vous connaissez
beaucoup de souffleur de verre mais il y
en a de moins en moins et je réalise
d'ailleurs pendant ce voyage qu'il y a
de moins en moins d'artisans de beaucoup
de matières des savoir faire qu'ils
disparaissent partout ça c'est un
problème la société dans laquelle
j'habite est en train de m'enlever ma
lumière à travers l'artisanat
je découvre énormément de choses parce
que face à ce problème en fait je me
penche sur la question de l'artisanat
est ce que veut dire à l'artisanat et
pourquoi on en est là aujourd'hui
alors je fais des recherches dans un
livre de richard sennett qui s'appelle
l'artisan je découvre que l'artisan il
ya très longtemps était le pilier de sa
communauté
sous le même toit
gérer son atelier la création et de
l'autre côté sa famille je pense qu'il
gérait pas sa famille mais vous voyez ce
que je veux dire c'était des sages dans
l'antiquité grecque
les artisans sont la classe moyenne
haute
ils ont un énorme pouvoir enfin pour un
grand pouvoir d'affluence d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui vous pouvez vous voyez bien
que lorsque leurs créations donc non pas
de prix
pendant cette antiquité une idée est
posée par quelqu'un qu'on connaît tous
ce qui s'appelle aristote il dit que
parce qu'on pense qu'il est frustré en
fait avec l'artisan qui considère un peu
comme un bourrin qui travaille avec ses
mains et qui a un peu trop de pouvoir
dans la société dans laquelle il habite
il dit que pour pousser la création il
faut séparer la main et la tête que
l'artisan est le concepteur doivent être
de différentes personnes je vous
imaginez bien que quelqu'un pour
quelqu'un comme moi c'est compliqué
heureusement j'ai un allié il s'appelle
platon qui pas longtemps après défendra
le concept enfin l'idée que justement
pour pousser la création à son plus loin
il faut que la main et la tête soit
attaché moi c'est ce que je défends
voyez c'est pas un métier facile entre
les mains j'ai mille plus de 1000 degrés
une matière qui me brûle me griffe me
ramène tous les jours à la réalité que
les choses sont finis que tout a un
début a une fin
cette matière ce savoir-faire me permet
de me reconnecter avec les gens avec qui
je travaille qui je montre comment
apprendre le langage de l'artisanat et
donc je partage un savoir faire
à ce voyage dans le monde de l'artisan
de l'artisanat je redécouvre avec ce
dialogue qui devient de mieux en mieux
nommé enfin de plus en plus fluide vu
qu'on parle du verre je redécouvre le
soleil je redécouvre l'afrique dans
laquelle j'ai grandi avec les couleurs
vibrantes sur les peaux noires le
brouillard les nuages
ces grands nuages dont je parlais
j'étais petit les fruits la végétation
je mets juste cette photo pour que vous
compreniez que je travaille en grand
même la neige l'hiver que j'ai découvert
quand j'avais 5 ans voyez grâce à ce
langage qui est mon savoir faire dans ce
monde d'artisans je reconnais qu tu ma
tête et ma main je connais que ma tête
ma main à l'univers qui m'entourent et
tout ça prend sens et me permet tous les
jours de vivre mon rêve depuis deux ans
s'cusez moi
autre chose qui me fascine c'est
l'univers ça c'est ma version l'univers
les planètes qui tournent autour du noir
si une table pas très pratique
elle est plutôt cool il ya deux ans j'ai
eu la chance d'ouvrir mon premier
atelier à paris qui est un atelier
vitrine j'ai une vitre de 6 m dans
lequel on travaille et tous les jours je
peux partager ma passion et mon savoir
faire avec les gens dans mon quartier le
mercredi après midi à la sortie d'école
tous les petits passent devant ce colts
à la fenêtre et regarde avec des grands
yeux et quand je vois c'est petit ça me
rappelle moi et je dis toujours dans dix
ans le douzième sera remplie de
souffleur de verre
vous verrez alors la bonne nouvelle
c'est que ces métiers cette façon de
travailler et de s'exprimer sont en
train de disparaître mais aussi soit en
train de se renouveler
on se renouvelle beaucoup d'associations
y contribuer heureusement la société la
conscience collective commence un peu à
se réveiller
je pense que les gens en ont marre de
passer deux heures à ica et d'en
ressortir sans avoir une trace du mans
je pense que les gens on a tous besoin
de se reconnecter avec les objets qui
nous entourent et on a tous besoin que
les objets qui nous entourent et de
l'esprit
quelque part c'est le métier de
l'artisan c'est de redonner de l'esprit
aux objets
grâce à cet atelier je peux en parallèle
de travailler dans le monde du luxe
fabriqué des pièces que même moi je ne
peux pas m'acheter je peux souffler du
petit verre pour les gens du quartier
je peux partager ma passion avec les
enfants du quartier ont savoir-faire
leur montrer que c'est possible de
travailler avec thin man dans cet
atelier je peux je peux faire vivre
d'autres personnes qui au tour de verre
et de notre savoir-faire peuvent se
découvrir
même le petit chien et il en profite
donc voilà en fait mon message il est
assez simple dans un monde qui suit
virtualise de plus en plus dans un monde
qui suit virtualise de plus en plus je
vous propose qu'on laisse plus de place
à cette idée de l'artisanat l'artisanat
entier ou la main et la tête sont liés
pour que l'humanité puisse avoir un peu
plus de lumière dans un monde où cette
lumière est menacée merci
[Applaudissements]